good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Tuesday I hope
everybody's having a glorious morning a
morning that is glorious and speaking of
Glory it's jackieo speaking of Glory
here I am hey guys how you doing daring
good speaking of Glory me speaking of
Glory it is me hi everyone and D andd
with no no no no no no speaking of Glory
it's Gloria it's Gloria calling glor I
have to stop singing on the podcast
we're going to get into that on Friday
on Friday we're going to get into it
we're going to get into kind of like
what's been going down there's a a bit
of drama in our lives no no it's kind of
like major it is kind of major we
haven't even spoken about it on a
personal level like one to one off email
like seven lawyers emailing us and you
and I you and I have been communicating
via email with our team of litigators
with our team of lawyers yeah um seven
business to deal seven attorneys and
we'll talk about it on Friday okay yeah
I don't think it needs to be discussed
before Friday no it wouldn't be
appropriate to discuss it before Friday
wouldn't be so today's Tuesday and I
know that doesn't sound amazing but let
me put some things in perspective okay
we need this okay like cuz I was
thinking today I'm like oh wait as I was
getting ready I'm like what day is it
Tuesday and I was like yeah okay yeah do
we wish it was Thursday of course but at
least it's not Monday like at least
we've already started do you know what I
mean yes but like there was excitement
on Monday yesterday and it was so much
to live for week a new and now we're
just in the thick of it I know and
there's not like a big new Taylor and
Travis story that we could like hold on
to that to buoy ourselves to but the
stories actually did come together
nicely today took a while but I feel
good with where they're at okay I'm I'm
excited about that I have a lot of
thoughts I know two of the stories I did
you know ask to discuss and one in
particular I have a lot of thoughts on
so I can't wait to get to that great
well we'll get to it soon just need to
catch up with the swirlies we recorded
redheads yesterday so you guys it's time
to become a redhead like stop being an
uncultured
uneducated swine swine sorry swine and
join the redheads we read great books we
just read none of this is true by Lisa
juel which tury recommended so if turdy
liked it and we liked it like everybody
likes it you liked it yeah okay it was
good right yeah it was super cute and
it's about it's like True
Crime by the way how much you hate that
[__] Josie like such a loser then also
that other girl was
like you're like so easily being taken
advantage of like you not's going on let
this Nut Job into her precious life with
her precious family kids oh sorry don't
want to spoil it but no that's really
not what it's about it's not at all so
I'm so glad everyone enjoyed love love
love ch's influencing the redheads while
the redheads influence the culture while
the redheads influence the culture and
yesterday was our 50th episode wow can
you believe that 50
books it's amazing like if you just stay
with with the redhe heads like you will
have read 50 books right just stick with
us you know what we didn't discuss that
I feel like actually would have been a
great story if you have some if you have
a story you want to swap out I guess
there's one Moshe posted it on Instagram
they did this big study on the reading
habits of Americans based on like age
group gender race and how many books
people are reading and I thought it was
really interesting like for women the
most popular was like True Crime and if
you've read more than I think 50 books
this year you're in the top like 0.01%
of readers it was really interesting but
like most Americans read one book in the
year that's what I read yeah barely
barely but then it was also really
interesting to see like you know genres
based on like ethnicity or race it was
super interesting let me pull it up
actually because there were some key
takeaways mosha post so much I don't
know how I'm ever going to find this
thing take your time but not too much
time no I won't take my time oh also
okay hold on reading we do it every day
reading in the evening and even when we
play oh
here 46% of Americans did not read any
books last
year 5% read more than one book okay wow
that's very little you guys we've got to
step it up you guys need to become a
redhead it's time the country needs to
join the redheads paper books are two
times more popular than ebooks that
makes sense oh by the way I forgot to
tell you guys I I left my Kindle on the
plan we saw your Instagram story we
don't feel sorry for you what the how
are you leaving on a plane what do you
put it in the pocket in the seat back in
front of you I must that's disgusting
it's so dumb like and by the way not
even Dum gross I wouldn't want it back
after that with the vomit bag fathom I
can't even fathom how I left my Kindle
on the plane I didn't even read on the
plane like why was what was it doing
out maybe Ben's trying to stop reading
that's on me I own that one white
readers prefer mystery and crime over
other genres black readers prefer
religion and spirituality and Hispanic
readers prefer history
young adults favor fantasy of course
Millennials favor history and older
readers prefer mystery and crime that's
so funny that like this whole like
movement of romance and you know reading
smut and like is like not represented
here at all well maybe that's because
it's kind of multi-generational
Multicultural no but it just feels like
these books like the Evelyn hug goes
like toate but they have taken over the
world that they're in the list every
week yeah where's the romance repres
and where's like the Taylor Jenkins read
where does she fall into it so how many
books did you read last year
42 you were in the 94th
percentile I'm in the 99th yeah you
little old me I just thought that was so
interesting that is interesting but it
is interesting how like you think book
talk has to changed the reading
landscape and in a lot of ways it hasn't
and this is not shocking but ebook
ebooks attract the heaviest readers
which makes of course I thought that was
fascinating I guess we don't need to
include it as a story CU I just did cuz
we just debriefed so we can stick with
the five that we have when does redheads
come out tomorrow I'm standing by the 53
how can you ask that
Thursday Thursday sorry in two days in
two days yes first Thursday of the month
which this month was on February 1st so
we had to get to Stepping we had to get
to stepping on recording rough yeah but
you know what we turned out always fun
to be with this swirly such a great
group such a great group of dynamic
readers with varied opinions of dynamic
women
women let's talk about no let's not I
had a very busy morning actually my home
is really coming together very exciting
I got my couches I got my drapes I
cannot wait I'm also hosting book club
next week and I was not going to host if
my couch was not going to come in time
but my couch came pressure's on are you
going to cook no but it's Baba yeah no
but I'm going to do like a kosher
catering like I'm going to really go all
out for the girlies they deserve it make
a CH they deserve like good food they
don't deserve whatever crap I can SC
together been cook I really I want it to
be and then like I'm I want my house to
be so clean like I don't want to have to
then like clean the kitchen after I cook
like I'll be ordering from like a kosher
butcher or something and what are you
reading oh I have to read the book it's
called like Kitty car oh the lives of
Kitty car something yeah Kitty car I've
seen it I think it was a rees's pck I
was tempted by it oh was it yeah I
almost chose it like once for the
redheads and then I didn't I don't
always like like I don't love when
something that be choose also ree has
chosen because it just feels like
everyone in the world is reading the
same book when we should be all reading
like more than one book and you should
be platforming multiple authors right
right and this author has already had
her moment so um actually I think that
was the month I chose adva and I feel
good about that adva and the Hollywood
wives this was like kind of similar um
but it looks like time might want to
read we almost chose what's the book you
just read on redheads strange s Diamond
but somebody in the book club had read
it darn darn darn yeah so um that's
exciting my house is coming along it's
so great when you start to like love
your home you know it's like so I can't
wait to get home and hang this piece of
art you know what piece of art just the
art that you bought me that's now going
in my dining room oh my gosh the Greymon
is it Greymon or who's the other one
slim marrons yeah one of them it's one
of them it's giving Italian landscape
it's going in my dining room it matches
perfectly and I'm so excited so it's
truly the gift that keeps on giving me
little old
me
so anything else you want to like catch
up on before we dive in no busy day
yesterday just doing a lot of personal
admin you know personal oh you know what
I actually made a Tik Tok this morning
that I wanted to bring up today because
there's this big conversation this
girl's video on Tik Tok went viral her
name is Dary and she does like beauty
makeup stuff and so she's like unbox my
PR with me I've been gone for a week and
Jackie there might have been 500 boxes
it was the craziest thing and it really
spawned to this conversation about like
the gifting industry and PR and you know
we've been having this conversation on
the toast for many years no one listens
to us been out on Tik Tok everyone's
talking about it so I made a Tik Tok
like giving my two cents and I wanted to
know like what's your thoughts and
experience on like the insane amount of
gifting that comes with being an
influencer obviously it's like first
world problem this isn't real but like
what are your thoughts my thoughts are
when it's good keep sending it when it's
crap you can keep it and you know it's
crap like Jackie I literally said that
in my Tik Tok I'm like at the end of the
day like what most people don't realize
I think a lot of people look at like the
gifting thing as like with envy and what
you don't realize is like it's all crap
it's all crap and you feel you don't
want to nobody like throws it away so
you want to donate it but you also feel
bad like just get getting rid of all
this stuff so you try and incorporate it
into your life and then you just have so
much crap it's crap it's crap on crap
but what I've noticed is I feel like
Beauty Brands used to send their whole
collection to influencers because it's
hard to guess someone shade but now
they're sending like four Shades yeah I
just saw Kylie's um Foundation launched
that I just saw Kylie's Foundation I've
been seeing some of the videos and I'm
really tempted to try it the thing is
though I love my foundation and I have
no issues with it I don't know how a
foundation could be better for me than
the one that I'm using Foundation is
also so personal but it looks thick I
like a thick granny Foundation you do
like a th I like full coverage I've
heard it's very matte and like drying I
don't know if that's your Vibe no but
that's not what I heard where did you
hear that like people reviewing it on
social media I feel like I need to just
try it but then it's like it's hard to
just try it because I still have to get
probably three colors to find my color
well you could go to Ulta could
I such a good point like seriously could
I no I mean yes actually you could if
I'm leaving the house look at my nails
look at my you guys don't want to see my
toes oh my God what I did to my toes I
tried to clip them Claudia they look
like dinos like raggedy jaggedy was that
Charlie or Harry pregnancy where I
clipped your toenails for you I feel
like Harry they were scary after after I
gave birth to Harry yeah they were
really long like we were all just like
coming over every day and she was just
like had her dogs out and I was like I
think for culture in my bed like nursing
my child I said for the culture we need
to get these dogs under control and so
she trimmed them but it's hard to click
your own toenails and even not as a
pregnant person yeah no but even like I
just clipped my toenails because they
were getting too long and I didn't do a
good job and why is it so hard oh you
know I did want to share something like
not to brag but I did like reach a new
personal Milestone yesterday okay at the
gym so like running is really hard for
me like I'm just like an extremely out
of shaped person between the vaping and
you know being obese for many years it's
just not something I can do um so I've
been trying to like run for like a full
song like ever since I started my health
Journey it's really hard I ran for four
minutes straight
yesterday bra thank you thank you and I
really feel as though the only reason I
was able to do it was because I pulled
up on YouTube the 1989 version of
Wildest Dreams ex Enchanted and like the
last four minutes of that when she's
just going so hard like it really it
powered me through and I was really
proud of myself I'm sweating so hard
it's like literally four minutes how
embarrassing is that whatever I did
it
you know on FaceTime when you do a
thumbs up now it does a thumbs up bubble
I'm so glad you brought that up because
I keep getting thumbs UPS from you and I
know you're not giving a thumbs up but I
actually did just give you a thumbs up
are you getting it oh no I'm on my
computer yeah no I'm getting it on my
comp I'm on my computer too I gotum I
got a thumbs
up obsessed okay cuz I just got the new
phone Grandma wait Jackie do you know
this
one you can send Hearts if you do heart
hands oh and two P signs hold
on okay one PE sign sends balloons or
does it and then twopiece sign sends
balloons and
confetti I didn't get that but I so
that's very cool let's get a pregnant
redhead I'm loving my new iPhone let's
get a let's get a redhead bride
yep because redheads are Triad wives too
like they get married in settle down
redheads get pregnant red redheaded baby
redheaded anything redheaded baby and
then also it's like okay so we have
pregnant man but not pregnant redheaded
man right well then it's a slippery
slope yeah yeah but they have to wait in
line now oh imagine if they did pregnant
redheaded man before at this point they
would no at the rate that things are
going yes that's actually like The
Logical Next Step yeah anything to not
get the Redhead variant but I'm so glad
I've gotten so much Outreach and support
from redheads the grp the redheads group
chats are popping off that I am speaking
for the people I'm the voice of the
people and you guys I'm happy to do it
it's time basically at this point it's
you and Shannon like yeah it is and
Shannon was just I saw after we recorded
that she was literally saying this on
her story that there's no redhead bride
she is a redheaded bride but if she were
a male bride then she'd have an emoji oh
Shannon's coming to town let me tell you
Shannon called me yesterday and it was
when my drapes were being installed and
she's like what does that sound I'm like
Oh my drapes are being installed she's
like oh my it's so funny my drapes were
just installed and I was like so excited
about my drapes anding Jackie then she
showed me like her bedroom I can't deal
with Shannon's house I wanted to burn my
house to the ground I was like oh she's
like show me yours I'm like no they're
not done yet no I when I was on her
podcast I was saying this to Shannon
this is like two separate things but
what I was said like her house is just
came together so quickly so done to a
tea but she says it's because of
tailored her best friend is like really
great with designning just tells her
what to buy but like the thing about
Chon is like oh she wants to paint her
kitchen cabinets it's done tomorrow like
she's so quick with it oh I need to take
my Christmas tree down at 6:00 a.m. on
December 26th she's so like she doesn't
waste she was wrong for that she was
wrong for that she explained why she did
and I understood like just that feeling
of needing to purge and she had moved so
much furniture around for her Christmas
setup and she had uh people staying with
her and they never got to see her house
as it is without all the Christmas crap
and like normal the to me that's just
like an extremely privileged thing to do
like she doesn't know what it's like
some don't have a Christmas tree she
doesn't know what it's like to not be
able to decorate for Christmas so to
take it down so quickly and swiftly and
so kind
of you know disrespectfully no she made
it made sense to me but I I mean I feel
the same way even the other day she
posted her messy closet and she's like
don't worry it was so messy like no
shade and she was like don't worry it
will be cleaned up today and it was
cleaned up today for me if that were my
closet 3 months later I actually relate
to Shannon in that sense like if
something that needs to be done I'll get
it done that day like I'm extremely
proactive but but like just except this
papsmear like I have been needing to get
a papsmear for like two months and I
just every day I'm like oh I have to
make the appointment today I have to
make the and I just can't make the
appointment when it comes to making
appointments I'm not your girl yes
you're not no but I've realized that's
something I can delegate to my husband
not my papsmear but appointments in
general I love that I love the phase of
growing up where you realize like our
husbands like can can help us like they
should take stuff off our PL and the
thing is our husbands love talking on
the phone love and I it's my weakness in
life and so I think that's perfect
situation where this is now your
responsibility love yeah love um okay so
I feel as though we've dded long enough
yeah yeah yeah I mean you know us we
could always further da we could wax
poetic we could Dilly further and Dally
further we could always dally further I
don't know about about
Dilly but she is so lost without further
Dilly dallying here are the fast five
stories that you need to know and major
major news is that the fast five stories
are brought to you by McDonald's that's
right we have reached Elite level of
podcasting McDonald's is today's sponsor
as toasters you guys know we are truly
wholeheartedly obsessed and in love with
McDonald's I think we talk about
McDonald's at least once a week on the
toast is there anything better than
getting home from a late night and
having McDonald's taking a long road
trip with your gal Pals and just
cruising on through the drive-thru no
there's literally nothing better also if
you're just a busy on the-go person kids
mouths to feed yourself included
McDonald's is so great it's just
fabulous and we're so excited to partner
with McDonald's to talk about their
classic Burgers which are hotter juicier
and tastier than ever before so much so
that the Hamburg burglar back on the
loose we have nothing but empathy and
respect for the Hamburglar because how
could you blame him for trying to get
the Big Mac he just deserves McDonald's
patties are cooked to Juicy Perfection
and the cheese is perfectly melted we're
talking a pillowy soft golden bun and a
big Mack Big Mac excuse
me and a Big Mac that now has more
special sauce in every bite We Stand
firmly with the Hamburglar because these
are truly McDonald's best classic
burgers ever you can try McDonald's best
burgers ever at a McDonald's New Year
and that's a fabulous thing about
McDonald's there's always one somewhere
you know so treat yourself it's only
Tuesday you know we have a lot more
living to do so get that get that burger
from McDonald's and treat yourself at a
McDonald's near you today's episode is
also brought to you by kiwi Co kiwi Co
Panda crate is a bimonthly subscription
for babies 0 to 24 months it's perfect
for brain building playmade fun it's
made with care kiico products are free
of BFA flat lates and Lead they use only
non-toxic water-based paints and
finishes so kiwo is a fabulous thing to
get for your kids I feel like what I've
learned by being a full-time Auntie
stay-at-home auntie is it is hard to
keep these kids engaged it is hard to
find toys that will keep them busy but
also intellectually stimulated you don't
want to just like pop them in front of a
screen for hours so kiwi Co is science
fact safe play when it comes to Baby
playtime trust matters and kiwo goes
above and beyond they're designed in
partnership with experts at the Seattle
Children's Hospital they're not only
safe and high quality but they're also
age appropriate and supportive of your
baby's growth so they support your
baby's rapid development with products
that support child-led play and
encourage open-ended exploration seure
your little one's growing brain through
fun and engaging play and it's designed
with care their thoughtful quality
design choices and materials promote
healthy development and they are
designed with high quality materials
ensuring that they withstand the test of
time so not only are you keeping these
kids occupied for more than five minutes
you're also engaging them these are toys
that are going to help them develop help
them learn discover new things build a
robot so unlock brain building play with
kiwi Co Panda crate get 50% off your
first month with code toast at
kiwico.com Panda that's 50% off your
first month that at
kiwi.com Panda promo code toast thank
you la you're welcome and thank you kiwi
Co our first story we've got some
musical beef today the first two first
one Nicki Minaj releases Megan the
stallion diss track called Bigfoot amid
their ongoing feud so Nicki Minaj and
Megan the stallion have been having a
musical Feud over the last few days last
week Megan the stallion put out a song
called his and there is a line on the
song about Megan's Law which is about a
law that requires um the sex offender
registry to be to register with the
state and we know that Nicki Minaj's
husband is a level two sex offender in
New York state so is her brother so this
line seems to be about a little bit of
of a disc towards Nicki Minaj the thing
is is that it could have been a disc
towards Nicki Minaj but Nicki Minaj like
took it personally and then released her
own diss track basically just kind of
outing her herself like as the target of
this lyric it probably was about Nicki
Minaj but it could have not been you
know yeah she had plausible deniability
but maybe there's stuff going on behind
the scenes where they because the the
origin of this Feud is weird they've
been they've worked together before and
they've been fine so it's like what
happened is this the first thing to
happen if this is the first thing to
happen yeah it's kind of an outsid
reaction but if there's stuff behind the
scenes and then Megan took it public
with this line Megan's Law now Nikki's
responding in kind she put out a song
called Bigfoot she and she put it out a
few days after the initial song came out
so she moves quickly and I listen to it
it's very good it's definitely about
Megan the stallion yeah so here are some
of the
lyrics this little begging W word
talking about Megan's Law for what's the
W word I don't
know they they bleeped it out they
blinked it out I was thinking wch or
which but like they wouldn't bleep that
out I don't know what's a W word sound
up in the comments even though it's word
yeah for okay this is here's the r this
L beg and W talking about hit this
little beg and W talking about Megan's
Law for a free beat you could hit Megan
Raw O if you a ghost riter party in
Megan
jaw wait if you a ghost writer party in
Megan's jaw look get it I think
like blow job yeah I think shots thrown
but I still ain't let Megan score bad
[__] she like six foot I call her
Bigfoot the [__] fell off I said get up
on your good foot because you know she
was shot in the foot by Tory Lanes she
was shot in the F foot by Tory Lan she
also accuses Megan of lying to Gail King
on CBS Morning about the details of the
2020 assault by Tori Lan oh
wow I remember when we reported on that
story Jackie said the name Tory Lan a
thousand times and every single time she
called him Tory
Lanz also I saw this morning it said
Megan the stallion was going on um GMA
she had a big
announcement and then I never saw what
the announcement I don't think GMA is
where you take your beef this whatever
she's announcing it's going to be you
know like a collaboration with the brat
stalls not like what her response to
Nicki Minaj anyways she also in the
outro Nikki teases there's a second
installment to the diss track and she
repeats lying on your dead Mama on your
dead mama she said oh ho the things
you've lied about even pertaining to
your mom you don't want them out okay
now since you think it's funny to speak
about people's families we'll all join
in we'll all play the reindeer
games
so here's where I stand I feel as though
we were just having the conversation
about Nicki Minaj like she's so funny
and iconic and like she's so deeply
problematic but like whatever you know
this was like a gentle reminder she is
married to a sex offender and related to
one and it's just like lowkey crazy it
really is and I think that Megan the
stall and loky got shot in the foot and
I feel like this is the third time like
it's been made into a rap lyric and like
people make fun of her I feel like the
rap community's actually been really
awful to her after she was literally
shot and I kind of stand with Megan the
stallion oh really yeah and then and
then Nicki Minaj like once this track
came out Megan the stallion like really
played this well she released the track
then Nikki responded Nikki's been going
insane on social media leaving the most
insane comments on like regular users
like people in the fandoms Tik toks and
stuff she's been like kind of acting
like a nut and Meg is just kind of
letting her act nutty so I do feel like
Megan won even though Megan like did
start it she did start it yeah I don't
know I I was going to say I think this
song like it's really good the lyrics
are cutting it's a good diss track like
she thoroughly dissed her yep she's been
dissed she's been dissed and I feel like
Nicki Minaj finds herself s in these
feuds
often so it's kind of like a Nicki thing
but at this point like I'm going to I'm
sticking with Nicki oh wow yeah and I
feel like when she was fighting with
cardi B we we didn't we didn't I where's
cardi B I stood firmly with cardi B
right um because I felt as though like
Nikki really couldn't handle not being
the only female rapper and and she
should have been more supportive even
though that's so much easier said than
done by the way like I honestly kind of
stand with Nikki on that um no I I mean
who knows where is cardi B that's a good
call who knows what the beef is I just
think time and time again like Nikki
she's hysterical she her music is great
like the fact that she wrote this
seriously disil track it's extremely dis
it's extremely disal in a matter of days
like she's the queen she's the queen for
reason she's a supreme talent I I don't
think anyone's going to argue that like
she really her personal life is a little
chaotic yeah oh we okay when we're
talking about this like I just have to
take that out of it because of course
she loses every time if we're oh okay oh
okay by the way you have to say that
yeah no no sorry like you're taking the
sex offender thing out of the equation
even though it's like a major part I
know it's hard to like just take out of
the equation
but I if we put it on the table there's
nothing else to talk about no it's so
true it's kind of like game over game
over so we kind of have to take it off
the table so we can even talk about the
diss track but that's unfair to mega no
stallion CU like facts are facts like
your husband's a sex event no it's like
and okay why we just like take stuff off
the table no I I
understand I just really like Megan the
stallion like I also really like Nicki
Minaj you know what what if we just what
if we just didn't take sides okay and I
think also with this like time will tell
we'll see how it
ages
yeah also I do think it's probably best
for Mega the stallion not to respond cuz
Nikki does look like a little Looney
yeah just like going off for days yeah
it's an it's a big response to a on line
yeah she just really also just outed
herself in responding for sure but
Nikki's not like koi like that like oh
maybe if I don't say anything like no
one will notice that it's about me that
it's my husband's a sex offender yeah
you know she's not like trying to hide
yeah that's true she like what' you say
say it again say it to my face yeah like
this just could never be me I'm so
averse to confrontation especially
publicly like I feel like we're really
not and maybe this is to our detriment
cuz this is like a huge part of being
like a podcaster and just like a an
internet person is like having beef it
is but then everyone who has beef they
like talk a big talk and then the second
the other person here they're like I'm
sorry I didn't mean it like that so true
but like should we start some beef like
for our
careers I think we need to have beef
with tan
Mojo no no I actually like I really like
her yeah me too and I also like her
co-host she has a podcast too
um do we have beef do we have curtain
beef well we'll talk about it on Friday
oh yes for sure we have beef we have
beef social media beef I feel like a lot
of the beef has been squashed recently
yes I would agree with you but there
really there was never like actual beef
we just like you know we're nor we're
girls like we just see other people on
social media and we're like e you know
no no but like no we've had beef and now
we don't have beef who are you oh oh
yeah yeah yeah oh you know what actually
yeah the beef is squashed no no okay cuz
that's the thing about squashing beef
like you need to move forward you it up
you don't move back and I do think it's
worth mentioning we're not going to
bring it up but like in the beef like we
actually were wrong yeah but yeah so
it's not like if we brought it up it
would actually only be like in a
positive light for the person we squash
the beef with yeah that they would be
forgiving but we're not going to talk
about it but just know like you're right
we currently have no internet beef I
forgot and we've talked about that beef
before we did have beef we do not have
beef anymore like there is it's
vegetarian it's vegetarian I actually
was just realizing I think I have beef
with someone who like I mean at least I
should I'm going to text
you oh my Jackie's laughing like an evil
witch and she has beef I definitely have
beef when I send you this person's name
you're going to be like yeah there's
beef there is beef and you know what I
hate her she's wrong and you're right
thank you I agree respond I don't think
so I mean that was humiliating for her
it would be classic me if someone like
responded like a diss in my DM and I
didn't see it it's so true like too busy
to beef too busy to beef too that's the
name of our diss track too busy to beef
and the thing about my beef is that if
you guys like what I what happened was
public
so there's nothing that like happened
behind the scenes like you guys could
maybe figure it out oh my God that's so
funny I totally forgot about that
yeah okay I guess we like lowy do have
beef
yeah yeah love beef are you ready for
our next wait also let me check to you
one more person who I feel like we might
have beef with me or you we we oh okay
Texas we united front if one of us has
beef all of us have beef oh yeah by the
way I stand with you against that other
[__] oh yeah that one like is a little
like yeah we do have beef with that
unfortunately we do have beef yeah and I
meant to tell you we actually just got
like an email about that beef you're
lying no I swear exciting how annoy how
annoying is this conversation for people
listening who don't who aren't us the
thing is everything that we're
discussing like it's it's all in the
public domain so if you've been paying
attention closely you could piece it
together yeah do I have beef with anyone
else well I can't did I say on this
podcast that I officially squash a beef
between Shannon and tins you did or
maybe it was on patreon freaking Fred
but it's okay A Week delay you had a
week exclusive on fre I'm bringing the
girlies together Shannon and tins beef
is over they squashed it they don't even
remember what it was about and like
they're both agreed just to like drop it
and be friends now they follow each
other
love love bring like that's the Barbie
movie
okay you know are you ready for our next
story which is more musical beef yes I'm
so excited about this one Zach Brian and
Walter Hayes are beefing Walter what
I Walter Hayes and Tony
Lanes Walker Haz and Tori Lanz yeah not
Tony Tori wait but it's a
man Tori it's Tori it's Tor it's a man
named Tori yeah it's a man confusing
confusing it's a redheaded pregnant man
Nam
Jory
[Laughter]
l oh
no oh no okay back to the
story oh God T Lanz Tor Lanz will
never it's like M like it's so
funny Lanz it's really you made it
French oh my
God oh my God I'm also cracking up that
like we told we spoke about that story
once I once I said Tory l time and then
we never spoke about it again it was
just giving like mic chop you
know Bo drop and I'm sorry like it will
always be Lanz for me I agree it has and
always will be Lanz and considering like
he shot someone and he's in jail like I
don't have to he doesn't deserve like
that I have to get his name right oh
1,000% also if it's Lane with a z like
that's probably not his real name right
right it's Lenz so it's Lenz anyways
Walker Hayes and Zack Bryan are beefing
because Zack Bryan woke up one day and
decided to be a little rude okay okay
okay and he TW yes however however he
woke up and decided to be rude but also
to tell a hard truth I'm sorry yeah no
but at the expense of someone yeah and
he said imagine being radio whoever the
hell that is hearing shake the frost by
Tyler Tyler Childers and being like no
no let's go with the Applebee song which
is a reference to the Walker Hayes fan
song called Fancy like which was huge on
Tik Tok and then there's a line about
Applebee so it's clearly about that song
right if people don't know like the
context in country Tyler Childers is
kind of this like more outskirts he's
very not like pop mainstream country
he's very folky but he's a really big
following and he has one of his biggest
songs called Shake the frost it's like
very he's very deep very country like
it's kind of poetic and the Applebee
song was like the number one song on
country radio for like three months and
it goes like this yeah we fancy like
Applebees on a DAT night got that
bourbon streak state with the Oreo shake
and some whipped cream and a top too
like it is it was played ever you
definitely know the song it was play
everywhere nonstop for probably three
months and it was some of the worst
months of my life like for real so I I
actually in its Essence I agree with his
point yeah but in order to raise up one
artist he had to throw some another
artist under the bus even though he was
really trying to make a commentary about
like radio in general and instead like
he bis merged Walker Hayes's name and
Walker Hayes is fighting back so he
responded to the tweet at first he just
responded with another tweet and it was
very mature what did it say I can't find
it oh it was just like you know
Different Strokes very very um mature
very you know a bigger
person let me find it I can tell you
exactly what it
was yeah cuz then after that he did a
little more
hold on take our time you're right where
is his
tweet oh Walker hay then responded big
shout out to radio for that Applebee
song Zach and Tyler praying y'all's
continued success so honestly had he
left it at
that I would have had a lot of respect
now he was insulted so he has every
right to respond but like Zack Bryan
like had a good point I'm sorry yeah he
did his response the first one was good
and then he decided to also put out a
song about the situation the lyrics
include Woke Up This Wait Wait so wait
wait so he took the high high road and
then like the next day changed his mind
and recorded a song about it yeah no I
think he's still on the high road
because it was a mature song with like a
mature message still not like a diss
track but it just was a little extra so
the lyrics go like this woke up this
morning read something mean something in
the orange says you're feeling green
felt like throwing punches I just held
him back because Jesus didn't die for me
so I could fight with
Zach that'll be me next time I'm getting
to a fight with my
husband
literally in the post caption so he
posted the song to his Instagram and
then in the caption he said me and my
buddies were talking about the whole
Zack Bryan thing they were saying they
appreciated how I responded I confess
that they only saw my best foot forward
I had a hundred smartass responses in
the chamber that I didn't fire off then
we got to talking about people in
general why we get insecure Etc mostly
about how artists size each other up
compare and talk trash it's obviously
our natural human tendency to be a
little butt hurt by anyone else's
success then we wondered about that why
on Earth we would do that as songwriters
knowing that 0.1% of us are actually
making it in this Biz it took me 18
years to feed my kids with music and
I'll still knock something I hear on the
radio cuz I didn't write it so we tried
our best to put it all in a twanger and
this is what we got I hope it makes
y'all talk about stuff that
matters like so mature we love yeah yeah
yeah but
like
I I feel as though I'm like annoyed that
like Zack Bryan comes off as the villain
here because I think his point like
needs to be spoken about like what is it
with country radio also just radio in
general how like the worst songs become
the most
popular what is that and not the worst
songs but there are like sometimes bad
not the best songs that they play over
and over again like why right and we're
forced into liking them mhm but I feel
like fancy like went viral on Tik Tok
not on radio and they started playing it
on the radio because it was so big on
Tik Tok perhaps that's actually a good
point so I don't know that that one's
like the best example but I do think
there is you know a a argument to be
made here but I think in general now
Walker Hayes is trying to like
capitalize on the moment I think he's
also trying to he sees that people are
talking about him people might not know
him as an artist and I think aside from
fancy like like he's a very talented
singer and songwriter and he writes like
soulful music not just Applebee's
jingles and he's trying to use this
moment to show everyone what a talented
artist he is like he wrote this song
What overnight and if you listen to it
he sounds amazing so I think he's trying
to use the moment to be like I'm not
just the fancy likee guy because I'm
sure part of him is like fancy like
isn't my best song either why is Radio
playing it by the way he definitely I
think that happens with a lot of singers
they like res that one song because it's
not emblematic of like who they are and
what they're capable of yeah I've like
been using the word emblematic so much
it's such a great word I feel like it's
emblematic of how great word is
yeah but also I I I do think it's a
little bit of a Miss in Walker Hayes's
caption for him to be like you know
jealous of someone's you know like Zack
bry's not jealous no I I don't think so
either I just really like Walker Hayes
we've interviewed him a few times at the
CM swe
a really nice person sweetie he's like
sober he's a dad he's really got like a
good head on his shoulders sweetie yeah
and I like what he said like it took him
18 years to like feed his kids through
his music like he's not going to be
knocking whatever song it is the song to
be the song to do that say song again
true Zack Bryan then did like post
another Twee being like I didn't mean
like to like bring down someone I was
just trying to make a point for sure but
you did bring someone down
and you they're down
they're going to pick themselves up
yeah and like I feel
like why you got to be
Walker why you gota be so rude it could
have been anyone but I just feel like
Walker really like he's not the biggest
artist like maybe go after like a Luke
Bryan song that stinks it's such a good
point like all those like OG country
guys like Luke Bry and Jason Al like
their music sucks no no their music
doesn't suck but like they definitely
have a corny song that's on the radio go
after that about Bumblebee song of Blake
Shon sunet repeat like that's the worst
song on the planet right like go after
one of them not the one song Walker Haze
on the radio but the thing is when Zack
Bri so true when Zack Bryan woke up and
decided to fire off his fire point he
wasn't thinking about this he was just
like I'm making a fire point no so true
no he wasn't thinking how will this
affect Walker's
day wait he wasn't thinking what about
Walker no he wasn't and that so that's I
guess there in lies the issue he wasn't
thinking about Walker but like he
doesn't me thinking about Walker he's
just a person trying to say
something aren't we all just people
trying to say something every damn day
lter every damn day so I'm GNA issue a
truths here yeah like let's kind of do
what we did with Shannon and tins you
know just you guys it wasn't meant to be
personal it's not like Megan's Law right
right it's not like Mr
Lanz also at the end of the day like
this is a moment for for Walker Hayes
which he really hasn't had
so yeah and it's a great way for him to
Showcase like his talent right I think
it's fine I think it's fine too are you
ready for our next story what number is
it number three yes and something that's
like kind of not fine oh no Nikki and
Bri Garcia formerly Bella are shocked
and disheartened by WWE sexual assault
and trafficking claims excuse me okay so
the sisters who were previously part of
the w we under the stage name the Bella
twins left the company last year and
they had to change their name cu the
company owned the Bella name so now
they're the Garcia twins we knew that we
talked about that I did know that but
like they will always be The Bella Twins
yeah but so it's like ex formerly
Twitter Garcia formerly Bella they
shared a joint statement toast formerly
breath toast formerly breath they shared
a statement on their respective
Instagram accounts about the recent
allegations of sexual assault against
the company along with its co-founder
Vince McMahan and WWE executive John
Jackie Jackie just let it go
McMahon next one he's he's literally so
famous the next one's coming up and it's
going to be worse okay and WWE executive
John lorian tus who's their
stepdad who stepdad the Bella sisters
you know their mom married that WWE
executive oh I didn't know that you did
you watched Bella's show I don't think I
did actually who am I talking
to no like you were obsessed with the
with like Diva like I never watched
Total Divas I only like just casually
fell into the Bellas one day I never
watched oh my gosh okay well their mom
was married to a WWE executive or is
married John they call him John okay
just leave it that John L a former
employee is accusing Vince and John of
sexual assault physical and emotional
abuse well they're two separate things
but this uh the former employee filed a
lawsuit claiming that she experienced
physical and emotional abuse sexual
assault and trafficking while working at
the company among her claims in the
Court docs she alleged that Vince pushed
her for a physical relationship in
exchange for her employment at the WWE
and that he had sexual he had recruited
Jon to have sexual relations with her as
well um is that what is that what makes
it human trafficking yeah and then so
they put out a statement and that's
their stepdad saying we are shocked and
disheartened with the recent allegations
against members of the WWE it has been a
lot to process since we found out this
past week just as you all did this is
something we don't stand for or from
anyone no matter who they are we want
all women to feel safe and supported in
the workplace and in their everyday
lives damn yeah yikes yikes and it's
also crazy how even though they're no
longer in the WWE and they don't even
have their name because of it like
they're still kind of the face and they
have to no it sucks like the WWE WWE
like literally took their name yeah but
they still are like having to answer for
the sins of the WWE yeah I I don't
really I don't believe in this like
culture where like everyone connected to
everything like has to talk on
everything it is their
stepdad but like they're not affiliated
with this company anymore I guess they
are like the biggest women to come out
of the WWE so it's like a nice thing for
them to stand in solidarity yeah but
this like and I'm sure they they do
stand you know like of course well no I
don't think they're for
draing yeah it's just kind like it's an
obvious statement right no like
statement culture I'm not like a huge
fan
of and like the instances where people
actually like should speak out they
don't so it's like always unnecessary
statements like I didn't think the Bella
Twins were involved in human trafficking
you know yeah yeah or that it was
something that they advocated for well
I'm not in their DMS or comments so I
don't know how like if people were
calling for this and so if they was in
response to that sending them the link
being like yikes Bell twins really hope
you say something yeah yeah or if they
just felt compelled to say something
yeah but they're saying it's definitely
awkward that's like their mom's
boyfriend husband
husband so yeah who knows they do a lot
of work as like podcasters and talking
so I guess in that sense it would come
up at some point
yeah but yeah crazy times are you ready
for our next story is it the next story
that's brought to you by the new lioncap
film scrambled yes it is what a crazy
coincidence scrambled a heartfelt yet
hilarious journey of self-discovery and
self-love it's written and directed and
starring leam mckendrick who is quote
among Indie wire's top female filmmakers
to watch this year so here's what the
movie is about it's actually I think
like a really relatable story especially
for the toasters who might find
themselves in a similar life stage so
she's a quintessential Eternal
bridesmaid her name is Nelly Robinson
obviously played by leam mckendrick she
constantly finds herself between
weddings baby showers bad dates so when
she begins to feel like the clock is
ticking she is faced with the Bleak
romantic prospects Nelly decides to
freeze her eggs setting her on an
empowering Journey To A Brave New World
where she ultimately discovers the one
she's looking for might just be herself
film threat says it's brilliant
storytelling you can learn more about
the movie watch the trailer at
lionsgate.com Movies SL scrambled I
thought the trailer was hysterical it
looked so cute so many familiar faces in
the movie too I also think like a lot of
people this is going to be like leam
mckendrick's like moment she's going to
end up being like a
major like move filmmaker movie girly
after this movie because I think that a
lot of people are going to it's going to
resonate with a lot of people it's in
theaters on February 2nd it is rated R
if you want to learn more watch the
trailer for The Scrambled movie starring
leam mckendrick you can do so at
lionsgate.com
movs scrambled that's s c r a m b l e d
like eggs get it no I do get it I think
that's a really clever title and it
seems It's also she scrambled in her
personal life and and the eggs of it all
today's episode is also brought to you
by manscaped getting ready for
Valentine's Day and don't know what to
give the gift to give the man in your
life no worries manscaped is here to
save your love story with all the new
performance package 5.0 Ultra snag 20%
off in free shipping with code toast at
checkout it is The Ultimate Gift to
elevate his grooming game and keep the
romance alive all year round so
manscaped is a great gift for the man in
your life for for Valentine's Day one
because it's just like a good gift but
also because like it serves you as well
you know it's like your man gross does
he have nose hair does he have ear hair
does he could you know trim the pubes a
little bit manscaped a gift for you but
a gift for him so the lawn mower 5.0
features it's an electric trimmer that
features skin safe technology which will
guard his sensitive areas against any
grooming mishaps um the performance
package 5.0 comes with a bunch of really
fabulous products like the refined
cologne um the beard hedger Pro kit
which designed to shape his Scruff
effortlessly it'll sculpt cheek lines
maintain beard styles and it'll
seamlessly handle even a thicker beard
it is a perfect tool for a polished date
ready appearance so the performance
package just comes with everything you
could possibly need it's like the
perfect gift it comes with multiple
things inside just one thing perfect and
we've got a code you can get 20% off and
free shipping with code toast
manscaped.com that's 20% off with free
shipping manscape.com when you use code
toast here's to keeping the romance
alive one smooth move at a time thank
you L incredibly smooth Smooth Criminal
our next story is the first and I think
what will be a series of stories over
the next two weeks which is Super Bowl
commercial collaboration pairs oh how
exciting I love these stories first one
elfl Super Bowl commercial collaboration
pair and they've teamed up with the cast
of suits for their Super Bowl commercial
love with Elf Cosmetics Elf Cosmetics
yeah remember last year they did
Jennifer koid she was having her big
moment with the sticky with the sticky
uh it's a primer so sticky and it was
like sticking to everything yeah so this
year the legal drama is going to be part
of the Super Bowl three of its stars are
reuniting on the small screen Gina
Torres Rick Hoffman and Sarah raffy
appear in the trailer for Elf cosmetics
new Super Bowl is that rickoff man is
obviously Louis lit yeah Sarah is
Donna and who was the first actress
these three people Jessica right yeah
yeah okay Jessica Donna and Lewis great
so they're in a trailer for the new
Super Bowl ad also now Super Bowl ads
have trailers and promos and teasers
which it's just a whole thing it's a
okay it is a lot but you're paying like
8 million for 30 seconds like milk that
[__] I I'm not complaining I'm just
saying I mean that's 8 million before
you even have to pay for production you
have to pay your stars pay for the sets
like it's just to get the commercial
yeah I don't know if it's 8 million I
remember a few years ago it was five so
I assume with inflation it's at eight
yeah the ad will promote the Brand's top
selling product of 2023 which is the
Halo grow liquid filter complexion bler
bler that's interesting like elf is such
an interesting company because they're
probably the best drugstore brand of
makeup like they've really cornered the
drugstore Market whereas like their
products are sometimes better than like
stuff from seph for and Ulta but their
whole kind of brand ethos is they like
steal other things so the Halo glow is a
$5 version of the Charlotte Tilbury
Hollywood Flawless filter and the
packaging looks exactly the same it's
the exact same thing so it's kind of
crazy that like they have a commercial
and Charlotte Tilbury doesn't you know
yeah crazy and then there's a bunch of
other celebs and personalities who are
like summoned to court and appear in the
ad as well oh wow so they're going all
out yeah I mean I wonder how much money
like elf makes the cuz when you think
about like the the brands that do Super
Bowl commercials it's the biggest
biggest it's like the Pepsi Co companies
Frito Le like it's Dorito it's soda it's
and that's why every Amazon every year
there's like randomly like a new brand
like remember last year was the farmers
dog yeah and we were like oh good for
them like a toast sponsor getting a
Super Bowl commercial there was also
Oatley yeah I feel like they like just I
read a story about Ole like how all
their milk is like poisonous or
something
or they went bankrupt something like
that something like that but those milks
that are not milk that's like a real
milk mhm could go either way you know
there's always like things that come out
I think like
Silk turned out to be really bad did
they soy milk
controversy I'm not finding what was the
Ole
story whatever um also I just when I was
looking Oley is now going to be having
desserts at
Carell that's pretty smart actually keep
Carell Carell dairy free no like like an
option keep carll carll unfortunately
Carell like is a dying brand so they do
need to do like annoying modern things
and Oley like is a good collab sick sick
I agree and that's what's wrong like
with culture culture like some things
can't remain agre as they are and I
actually think that's a great segue into
our fifth and final story which is a
push into the future and I want to get
tur take okay because Elon Musk says
that the human patient is recovering
well after neuralink implanted their
brain chip so neuralink is one of elon's
company where they're working on like uh
brain chips where they implant them into
the human and then they can communicate
with human brain no it's like you can
control a computer with your brain
that's the thing yeah yeah so up until
now they had been using like pigs and
animal testing but they just did a human
patient for the first time Elon shared
on X that the unidentified patient is
recovering well after they received the
implant on Sunday he said initial
results show promising neuron Spike
detection he did not provide any
additional information regarding the
patient's condition of the procedure the
neuralink is a quarter siiz chip implant
and has dozens of tiny thread-like
electrodes the electrodes are then
implanted into the brain itself and
relay electrical signals from neurons
the chip is placed in the brains region
that controls the intention to move so
Elon uh talks about how it would control
phones and computers just by thinking he
said initial users will be those who
have lost the use of their limbs he said
like imagine if Steven Hawking could
communicate faster than a speed typist
or Auctioneer that is the
goal okay well now when you put it like
that cuz I was about to be like this is
[__] weird like this is really some
Black Mirror type [__] yeah it's not for
me at this moment me neither but but
like when you think about the future
like Year 3000 like you do think about a
world in which like your brain can
control your phone or whatever and like
this is the first step it's just freaky
as [__] because this is this is AI on
crack yeah yeah and when if people think
AI is scary like I think this is
frightening but using it as like a
medical device for like people who have
lost use of their limbs like that to me
is way less intimidating and scary
that's like always
a good example of the positives of
technology I remember those Super Bowl
Microsoft commercials where they would
show people using Microsoft Technology
people who are handicapped and how
amazing it is I feel like that's always
like the pro for technology and then the
con list just keeps going yeah but I
remember elon's book when he talked
about the reasons for neuralink I wasn't
totally against it but it's just like
not for me and not something that I feel
like I need to see in the world but he
feels like it's important for the
advancement of soci iety right I also
think like Elon is very
um particular and sort of uh
conservative when it comes to like the
advancement of Technology he's not he's
he's all for like safe AI you were
saying that so I do sort of trust his
judgment here a little bit it's not like
he's one of these crazy Geniuses who
will invent anything at any cost no
matter what it tell like he's very I
think um prudent yeah I agree so I I do
think he's the right person to be doing
something like this and I do trust him
cuz he is conservative and he doesn't
like just want to build robots and
machines that are just going to take
over the world for the sake of it
because and that chip could just like
take over your braid and you're just
like a zombie robot doing whatever chip
says right right right right like he's
probably building chips so that someone
else doesn't build it first and create a
chip like that right right right so we
have to support as much as we can I'm
just saying like you know maybe the
future is not for me little old me I
agree no like even the way you just said
like so that somebody else doesn't
create a chip that could take over like
are you kidding no but like that's
possible chip on chip crime it's going
to happen it's going to happen it just
feels like you know it feels like a lot
yeah but these are questions for the
elong of the world
to Grapple with and we just read about
the headlines yeah this is where it
feels you know kind of great like
ignorance like being dumb it's like
these are not my problems I know but I
feel like with AI this year like it
really crept up on us even AI ethical
issues we were just talking about last
week like with the Taylor Swift photos
yeah it's so true like I I went from not
knowing what AI is to like being
extremely concerned extremely concerned
but also like utilizing AI enjoying some
elements of AI but now we're kind of
like in this we're all privy to this
debate of like how smart should AI be
how intelligent should it be yeah and
like should there be litigation around
Ai and like laws and they're probably
should but even in the in
the software of it in the coding of it
that's where like the Elon come in and
they like decide before it gets to that
point of like what ai's limitation
should be
right damn these are Big questions we're
dealing with here today big big
questions big huge
huge um so that's our show and what's so
exciting is the next time you hear from
us it'll be Wednesday and like we can
just kind of breed the sigh of relief
that we're pretty much halfway through
the week we can hump our way through the
week so just keep that in mind keep your
chins up today girls like you'll be okay
you'll get through it we love you dearly
thank you so much for listening to the
toast Monday Morning Show where we
deliver the fast life stories that you
need to know every Mond Friday on
YouTube watching us on YouTube please
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up tented we are love you bye love you
bye